what you're looking at depending on who you
ask is either a revolution for the internet
and countless Industries as we know it like in all
seriousness I compare it to the internet or the
greatest Ponzi scheme in human history that whole
thing is a promise that you can get rich for free
accused of being all of these things is the world
of cryptocurrencies or the other labels associated
with it nfts blockchains web 3.0 from the bizarre
onslaught of celebrity promotions and endorsements
I got an ape Too part of the same Community
we're both apes to the eye watering numbers and
headlines digital artist people the final bid 69
million dollars oh my God to the grandiose claims
about its potential it's the biggest technology
that has ever happened in the I once described the
world of cryptocurrencies as a story and I did
that in hopeful optimistic tones and now now I
don't think is the story that I initially thought
it was they only make money because some other
sucker lost more have fun staying poor it amazes
me that anybody is buying into this they are
decentralized ponji's teams the only thing that
you have to show is Ponzi schemes it's all [__]
oh for me and many others it began here what
you're looking at is a piece of artwork by
a digital artist called Michael Joseph
winkelmann otherwise known as people on
February the 25th of 2021 this artwork was put
on auction bidding started at a hundred dollars
it eventually sold for 69.3 million dollars
making it one of the biggest sales in digital
art history that's what I do feel Super
Lucky what happened afterwards foreign
[Music] Halls that it doesn't exist in physical
form it is only available digitally it's the
first nft ever sold at auction non-fungible token
nft nfts are non-fungible token explain nfts to
people that don't know what you're talking about
because I don't know what you're talking about it
was like suddenly the term nft was just everywhere
Jack Dorsey co-founder of Twitter sells a picture
of his first ever tweet as an nft Jack Dorsey
auctioning his first tweet as digital art 2.9
Million Dollars even popular internet memes
were selling as this nft thing Nyan Cat 590
000 Charlie bit my finger 760 999 dollars
disaster girl five hundred thousand dollars
Doge 4 million dollars overly attached girlfriend
411 000 Bad Luck Brian 36 000 Scumbag Steve 57
000 you had singer songwriter Grime say killing
six million dollars worth of digital art as nfts
people were changing their profile pictures on
social media to nfts that they had purchased
it was like flexing an expensive car or a watch
and then suddenly all these big celebrities and
artists and influences were also replacing their
profile pictures with nfts and announcing their
own purchases of nfts and the Apes the Apes
were were part of this bigger project of nfts
called board ape Yacht Club I mean you had Snoop
Dogg Eminem DJ Khaled little baby post Malone
Stephen Curry Gwyneth Paltrow to name a few
all of them purchasing these pictures of apes
for sometimes hundreds of thousands of dollars
and amongst this sea of high ticket sales you
would hear that this is all part of something
revolutionary it's the biggest technology that
has ever happened in the history of life outside
of things like fire regardless of how much you
knew about nfts there was one message that was
really clear behind every story every headline
there was an underlying premise something is
happening and there is a lot of money to be made
[Applause]
I asked you to explain nfts so popular talk
show host Jimmy Fallon does this segment
on his show with Paris Hilton where
they show off their pictures of Boris
uh here's my this is my yours is so cool I love
the red heart sunglasses I love the captain hat
it reminded me of me a little bit dude look
at this they look like they could be friends
they're buddies [Applause] uh this was the point
in which I started to wonder okay what is actually
happening and I think a lot of people started to
as well you start to realize that the purchase of
people's artwork that wasn't done through 69.3
million dollars in cash that purchase was made
using cryptocurrencies in fact all the nft
purchases that we were seeing they were done
through cryptocurrency the mysterious individual
who purchased people's artwork that went by the
pseudonym metakova turns out it's this guy called
Vignesh sundarison who is already a cryptocurrency
entrepreneur and had a working relationship with
people months prior to the big sale and whilst
there was all this talk about the Revolutionary
potential behind what we're seeing there was
another side of the story that was being painted
by people who are far more skeptical and those
voices had a clear warning what you are witnessing
is a Mania we've got this system that is gleefully
and gloriously corrupt a Mania that is being
driven by greed get rich quick by investing
in crypto currency Mass delusion my Abe is an
inner reflection of myself or as other critics
put it it is a giant and scan that has some of the
largest names Brands Venture Capital firms backing
it knowingly or not nfts were just a component
of a much bigger machine with a lot of moving
pieces and when you put those pieces together it
creates a machine for one of the greatest scams
in human history and it all begins here with
a mysterious invention and a failed Revolution
2008 that's where this really begins Apple
shares were just getting hammered this morning
we're down by between three and four and a
half percent generally the United States is
going through a recession it hasn't seen since
the Great Depression the consumers strangled
they're watching their housing prices go
lower they're watching their 401ks get
diminished you created the mess we're in and
now you're saying sorry amongst the backdrop
of this all a mysterious individual is working
on their own invention on the 31st of October
they send an email to a cryptography mailing
list the email begins I've been working on a
new electronic cash system that's fully
peer-to-peer with no trusted third party
it was signed by somebody under the pseudonym
Satoshi Nakamoto whoever this Nakamoto person
was they had a vision the vision was to create
a type of currency that existed digitally that
could be controlled by no government or single
individual that could be used to transacting
globally no matter where you were or what time
it was the name of this currency and invention
Bitcoin on January the 3rd 2009 Nakamoto launches
his invention creating the first ever Bitcoins
to exist it was an attractive pitch you know
especially to people who held anti-state control
sentiments you know we're talking about anarchists
techno anarchists Libertarians cypherpunks these
were individuals who likely saw the government
the banks the entire financial institution as
just untrustworthy that they they can't be
allowed to control monetary policy and it was
these factions that became the first adopters of
Bitcoin influencing its early culture the goal was
simple preach the message of Bitcoin to others
and increase its adoption Bitcoin was kind of
like a religion of its own right like Satoshi
Nakamoto was this jesus-like figure that would
communicate with his disciples on online forums he
would talk of this Future Vision of the world you
know one where the dollar no longer existed and
all transactions would be made through Bitcoin
the global currency of the people that was owned
by no Central entity to those early a adopters
of Bitcoin they really felt like they were on
the cusp of something revolutionary it just so
happened that the more people started buying into
the message the higher Bitcoins value Rose and the
more people were willing to like put real dollars
into buying Bitcoins Bitcoin is now up to 111
Bitcoin started drawing attention from places it
probably wasn't expecting or even wanting the guys
in suits you know the the big money the people
who saw Bitcoin as revolutionary but perhaps
more importantly as an opportunity the Winklevoss
Twins were a perfect example of that I mean here
you have two twins who have graduated from Harvard
they've won a settlement for 65 million dollars
against Mark Zuckerberg for stealing their initial
idea of Facebook they found out about Bitcoin on a
holiday trip to Ibiza and they started buying
as much as they could they were stockpiling
the currency it was by around 2013 that they
were rumored to own about one percent of all
Bitcoin in circulation that I think was a perfect
early warning of what was to come foreign Bitcoin
was doomed from the start that's what a lot of
crypto Skeptics will tell you and I understand
why relying on computer code and the ideals of
tech anarchists probably isn't the best place
to entrust a reimagining of the financial system
Bitcoin had a fixed supply of 21 million coins
which makes it deflationary by Nature so if one
Bitcoin is worth more tomorrow than it is today
why would you want to use it to transact with
it's a pretty bad incentive to have if you're
trying to make a Global Currency but that is
already assuming that Bitcoin had the technical
capabilities to become this worldwide currency
which it didn't I mean Bitcoin had scaling
issues thanks to design decisions that Nakamoto
themselves had made it could only process seven
transactions per second I mean compared to
other traditional payment networks like Visa
which can process 1700 transactions per second
or Mastercard which handles 5 000 transactions
per second and keeping the Bitcoin Network
running wasted a lot of energy Bitcoin aimed
to be decentralized meaning no government or
single entity had control over it but in order
to do that Nakamoto employed what is called a
proof of work consensus model all this meant
was that computers on the Bitcoin Network would
be forced to use real world energy in order to
solve algorithmic problems and whichever computer
solved the problem first would be rewarded with
more Bitcoins it was a process called Mining
and that process is insane mainly wasteful of
energy and what ends up happening proof of work
incentivized this arms race between computers on
the Bitcoin Network all of them looking to build
more and more powerful computers to have a better
chance of mining Bitcoin and the more powerful
those computers grew the more real-world energy
they ended up taking despite the fact that
the transactions per second remain the same
most Bitcoin mining done today is done by huge
mining farms in warehouses Bitcoin for the most
part failed in its objective of trying to become
a Global Currency outside of illegal use purposes
Bitcoin just wasn't being used to transact
with so the obvious question becomes how how
is it that despite its failings Bitcoin still
survived and is very much present to this day
but that's just the thing the Bitcoin that we see
today is a shell of its former identity where most
of the purchasing of Bitcoin today happens
on centralized exchanges that have to comply
with the laws of centralized institutions in the
instances where you've heard about Bitcoin or if
you've ever been encouraged to buy Bitcoin under
what context is that always framed by 2014 the
mysterious Satoshi Nakamoto effectively vanished
from the internet and hasn't been heard from since
what was left of his invention was no longer
a currency it was something entirely different
Bernie Madoff this was a guy who was well
respected on Wall Street he ran a brokerage
firm with a wealth management Branch he had many
clients investing with his firm under the promise
of great Returns on their money until the FBI
arrested him this morning after he told senior
employees yesterday that his business was a giant
Ponzi scheme Madoff had been running the largest
Ponzi scheme in history for the last 17 years
and potentially longer worth around 64.8 billion
dollars he would essentially put his investors
money inside a bank account and then simply pay
out early investors with the money that new
investors were giving now Madoff eventually
pleaded guilty and he was in prison up until
his death in 2021. that is the essence of Eddie
Ponzi scheme people invest into the scheme under
this promise that they're going to make a great
amount of returns and then early investors are
paid using the money of new investors and this
process is repeated on and on until eventually you
run out of new recruits to keep investing money in
scheme or eventually people start trying to cash
out and it just collapses which tends to leave
early investors with profits and the large
majority of others with nothing but losses
people hearing about Bitcoin would hear about
two things one that it was revolutionary and
two that it was valuable that if you buy now you
could be rich later if you really really want to
become wealthy in the future I would suggest you
take one freaking dollar buy some Bitcoin Bitcoin
to me it's not just an investment it's not just a
maybe a get rich quick scheme as a lot of people
put it but I see it as the future of currency I
see it as the future of the financial system so
you realize that most of the people buying Bitcoin
they're not buying it to use as a currency they're
buying it as an investment and therein lies the
contradiction because the more people who used
Bitcoin like an investment the less liable Bitcoin
became as a currency the very thing it's being
pitched as being revolutionary as so you know
what you end up with right Bitcoin is a get rich
quick scheme the promise is you can get rich for
free magical internet money anyone who buys into
the idea of Bitcoin is doing so to sell it for a
higher price at a future date and the people that
buy it of those people are also looking to sell it
for a higher price at a future day the only way to
make money from your Bitcoin investment is using
the money of new investors you hear about people
making money in Bitcoin they only make money
because some other sucker lost more and unlike
Bernie Madoff right who gets all the blame and
dissatisfying jail time at the end of his story
here you have an entity that isn't owned by anyone
or some would argue isn't a decentralized currency
a decentralized Ponzi scheme now Ponzi schemes are
kept Alive by continuously finding new recruits
and new markets to tap into so that money is
continuously being poured into the scheme and so
you start to see this similar incentive develop
in the crypto space this desperate need to find
a use case for this stuff and that use case has
to be revolutionary enough to justify its Rising
value Bitcoin may have been the first part of this
machine the things we're about to get a whole lot
more interesting Bitcoin had something going for
it the blockchain system that kept it running was
somewhat unique okay so let's not complicate
things right you can think of Bitcoin like a
digital spreadsheet that records transactions
being used in the currency it's not a physical
coin it's just data on a database after a
certain number of transactions are made a
brand new spreadsheet is created that links to the
previous one and on and on and on it goes instead
of using real names users are recognized through
what are called wallet addresses which appear as
a random string of numbers and letters and all
of this is kind of kept together using computer
code cryptography and the network of miners
that are running it which is where the word
cryptocurrency comes from so what was essentially
just an immutable append-only database was touted
as revolutionary you know blockchain was no longer
just blockchain it was blockchain technology and
it wasn't long before people started to see the
success and the ideals that Bitcoin was based off
and begin creating their own cryptocurrencies
using this blockchain system [Music]
vitalik buterin a teenager who decided to quit his
favorite video game World of Warcraft after his
warlock character had a damage component removed
by the game developers vitalik says that he cried
himself to sleep that night that was the day that
he realized the horrors the centralized Services
bring it sounds a bit ridiculous but vitalik
would end up discovering Bitcoin in 2011 and
he would start writing for a Bitcoin magazine it
all appealed to his ideals in 2015 vitalik and
several other co-founders launched the creation
of their own blockchain based invention it was
called ethereum much like Bitcoin ethereum had
its own blockchain and it had its own native
currency which was called ether there was one
important difference though you see ethereum
allowed its users to actually program applications
on its blockchain put it this way if Bitcoin was
like a spreadsheet then ethereum was like an Excel
spreadsheet that allowed users to create functions
to perform various different tasks because it was
you know a little more advanced it was a glimpse
of Hope at finding the Revolutionary use cases
in the cryptocurrency world needed in order to
justify the growing value that was being pumped
into the system so what was the first thing that
people started using ethereum for creating more
cryptocurrencies and today we will be creating
our own cryptocurrency in under 10 or maybe
even under 5 minutes rather than needing to
create your own blockchain and network you could
just use ethereum's blockchain to create your own
cryptocurrencies or crypto assets as people called
them these assets that existed without their own
native blockchain were called tokens there are now
over 1500 cryptocurrencies it became known as the
Ico Mania it was supposed to be this new way to
fund your business businesses could create their
own token coins release what is called a white
paper which explains what the project aimed to
do and then they could sell those tokens to the
public otherwise known as an initial coin offering
I see a whole wave of these token coins were
being released some of them parodies and others
were just blatant scams Bitcoin the Whopper coin
Trump coin Kodak coin insane coin but here it is
so I created dictator coin Jesus coin was a token
coin that was promising to decentralize Jesus on
the blockchain on its white paper its creators
stated they were in early talks with churches
to provide Miracles exclusively to Jesus coin
owners Ponzi coin was very much open about the
fact that it was a scam their website literally
said it right there is as much as a scam as 99
of the icos out there but it's more transparent
about it Ponzi coin still managed to raise 250
000 it didn't matter if the idea was good enough
or not or if it even solved the problems it was
claiming to solve all the mattered was that
people believed in the token enough so that
the value would rise and it would pay off the
early investors who got in at the start there
was one that you invested in that saw like
two thousand percent growth last month yeah
that was damn recording icos also marked the
beginning of an unlikely friendship between
those in the cryptocurrency space and influencers
and celebrities if token coins were fueled by hype
and detention then celebrities and influences were
the ones that were running the gas stations famous
professional boxer Floyd Mayweather along with
producer DJ Khaled were paid one hundred thousand
dollars and fifty thousand dollars respectively
to promote the token coin Centro Tech in 2017.
centratec was a project that was promising to
deliver Financial Services to the cryptocurrency
world the queen had raised 32 million dollars
turns out they lied about their CEO who wasn't
even a real person that existed they lied about
business deals with MasterCard and visa and its
co-founder Sam Sharma was eventually sentenced to
eight years in prison icos effectively became a
casino to gamble unregistered Securities but you
have to remember the hidden incentives no matter
how fraudulent or bizarre everything looks on
the outside in the crypto world you have to
keep clushing a potential use cases or or anything
that will justify its value constantly rising to
new investors and whilst the Ico Mania of 2017 was
continuing a whole new idea was coming to fruition
so how many of y'all have heard of this new
game that came out recently I don't know how
you how how do we actually describe what these
things are and today we're talking about crypto
kitties crypto kitties was probably one of the
first nft projects to make it into the spotlight
crypto kitties crypto kitties the viral blockchain
based game that sparked a global craze or virtual
cast it's a picture of a cat you logged onto the
site you created an account that was connected to
your crypto wallet and you'd play this game in
which you would collect breed and sell virtual
cats for cryptocurrency the key pitch here though
is that every cat is its own unique token that
exists on the ethereum blockchain making them
what you would essentially call non-fungible
or as they're often called now a non-fungible
token an nft think of it like a digital Beanie
Babies now if that sounds a little weird it's
because it is crypto Keys became like its own
Mania it generated three million dollars within
its first week of launch and accounted for roughly
10 to 13 of all traffic on ethereum's network and
where was everyone's Focus during that Mania okay
that's two thousand seven hundred dollars for
this little guy why use these cryptokitties 450
000 for this ugly mug the same reason you started
out with the cryptocurrency to make guys this is
a potential way to make some money this insane
most users are trying to breed their cats at
the moment not just because it's kind of cold but
also because they can be very expensive there are
thousands of people playing on the crypto kitties
website once everyone started rushing to join in
on the hike the economics of the game began to
falter as the supply of crypto kitties stretched
far beyond the demand eventually leading to a
crash in the price of crypto kitties and a full
in average users because as you continue to see
time and time again almost everyone was there to
make money but what remained of that Saga was the
idea of non-fungible assets a brand new package a
brand new pitch a new route to find use cases
for cryptocurrencies and blockchain Technology
this stuff was initially pitched to digital artist
the idea was that you would make artwork then
tokenize that artwork which just means turning
it into a token that exists on a blockchain like
ethereum if you wanted to know who owned the
artwork all you had to do was just go and check
the blockchain records and see which wallet
was associated with the artwork in theory you
could digitally verify the ownership of your
art sounds exciting you might think I did too
digital artist Michael winkelmann otherwise
known as people began in challenge in 2007
where he would create one piece of artwork every
single day and continue to do so throughout the
years it was known as his everydays collection
but to me the bigger project is this long-term
everydays project which is a project that
I've been working on you know every single
day for over 12 years it was reportedly around
October of 2020 when people was put in touch
with an anonymous nft artist called pack and pack
informed people about the world of nfts only a few
months later he would end up auctioning a piece of
artwork that contained a collage of the first 5000
images of the everyday series titled everydays
the first 5 000 days 69.3 million dollars was
how much it sold for in The Ether cryptocurrency
one of the largest sales in digital art history
the very sale that sent the search term nft
skyrocketing so now the question becomes
who decided to make that purchase so you
purchased a collection of 5 000 pieces of
digital art that anyone can easily see online for
69 million dollars why did you do that [Music]
well as they were later revealed to be Vignesh
sundarison a crypto entrepreneur who had recently
co-founded a crypto investment firm with his
business partner called metapurse only a few
months before this big 69 million dollar purchase
metakovan and his business partner had already
bought another collection of nfts from people for
over 2.2 million dollars they actually wrote a
blog post about their purchase alluding to the
fact that this was only part of a much bigger
project that they had in mind that will quote
flip the art World status quo on its head and
what was that project that they were talking about
the B20 token coin they were going to bundle their
purchases of people's nfts collection and put it
in a virtual Museum where those who purchased the
B20 token coin could access and view the artwork
owning the B20 token was supposed to represent a
type of fractional ownership in the virtual Museum
and the contents inside of it here's the thing
metakovan and his business partner conveniently
owned 59 of the total supply of B20 tokens beeple
was also given two percent of that Supply people
and metakovan already had a working relationship
before the big everydays 5000 sale when that
sale happened and the media frenzy ensued the
B20 token Rose in value to 23 as more people
began obviously looking into who metokovan was
people have accused that sale of essentially
being a giant marketing stunt to increase
the value of the B20 token even in their cools
together you can hear people Express skepticism
around the whole thing only for metakovan and the
others to kind of bring him around other artists
I can almost guarantee will not like this like
they will not like you taking their work and like
and likes and reselling those pieces I that I
would be very surprised if other artists did
not have a very strong dislike of that but what
I find the most insane about this Saga was that
the B20 virtual Museum that was supposed to flip
the art World status quo was nothing impressive
the B20 token has fallen over 99 in value since
its all-time high despite all of this metakovan
cells send headlines skyrocketing suddenly
nfts were being craded out of internet memes
or anything really that was culturally relevant
to the internet from the outside all you had to
know were that nfts were revolutionary and there
was a lot of money involved you didn't even have
to know that they were intrinsically tied to
the world of cryptocurrencies or blockchain a
successful repackaging once the sale of memes and
other one-off nft sales cooled down it became more
popular to start buying into nft projects these
contained up to thousands of nfts inside of them
usually following a certain theme or concept what
are crypto chunks this these are the crypto Parts
25 by 25 pixels yeah they're icons of zombies and
uh aliens zombies and yeah they all have different
Mohawks and glasses and beard types and I mean
what is Cool Cats the coolest nfts on the Block
shoot I get a lazy lions and if they've been
thinking about joining this amazing Community
clone X this project is previously known as
Akira's Nikki vampire it's got pudgy Penguins
on The Chopping Block today they're selling us
something called mini bits just as it had been
with Bitcoin and token coins the name of the game
was about hyping up a project that you can sell it
for profit later nfts though were cooler than your
average token coin so they had art behind them you
could show them off by replacing your social
media profile picture with an nft you purchase
more so than ever hype and attention became an
important part of growing the value of an nft
which brings us to the Apes one of the most
significant projects created after people's sale
was the board ape Yacht Club otherwise shortened
to just basey founded by the company Yuga Labs
the project featured 10 000 different pictures
of apes with this distinct board expression on
their face the ball rape Yacht Club project had
managed to arrive into the nft space at just the
right time about a month after people was big sale
there were a few popular people inside of the nft
space already one of which went by the name of
Jimmy McNeil's otherwise known as Jimmy eth on
Twitter who shortly after finding out about the
project announces their purchase of hundreds of
board ape nfts then another popular figure in the
nft space pranksy who had around 50 000 followers
at the time tweets their own purchase of 250 board
eights which later grows to 1 250. and all the
time these guys are tweeting about their purchases
to their followers it starts to create this Buzz
inside of the crypto space you've probably seen
all over Twitter this crazy crazy thing with
just after 12 hours of its official launch the
Bassy collection sold out giving yoga Labs an
estimated 2.8 million dollars in Revenue pranksy
starts selling some of his Apes to NBA players who
start tweeting and changing their profile pictures
to those Apes in August the popular DJ Steve oh he
tweets his own forty thousand dollar purchase of
a board ape to his millions of followers hashtag
eight follow ape began trending immediately
famous digital artist people tweeting about
it and creating an artwork about it which will
continue to drive up the price of board Apes
me a friend one of the shadiest parts about
everything that followed were the Blurred
Lines between celebrities and influencers
clearly manipulating a market to pump up the
value of their nfts and genuine posts simply just
showing off their purchases you had Justin Bieber
in January of this year posting a picture of a
board 8 number 3001 to his 251 million followers
a purchase that was reportedly worth 1.3 million
dollars everyone sort of assumes that the Justin
was the one that made the purchase himself right
and he's just posting it on his Instagram but then
Twitter users started to look into the records and
they find that Justin's supposed crypto wallet had
received 900 ether from another wallet address
and that wallet address was associated with an
individual named jean-pierro de Alessandro or
as many others May recognize him Justin Bieber's
business partner and Jan Piero owned his own nft
collection called in-betweeners which Bieber had
been promoting on social media already in those
posts no disclaimer was made suggesting that
Bieber had been paid to promote them I just got
my first nft are you dead what was it I through
moonpay in some of the announcements from
celebrities about their nft purchases there
was this constant reference to a company called
moonpay thanking them for help with purchasing
their nfts I got an ape too because I saw you
on the show with people and you said you got a
moon pay turns out moonpay was a company that was
launched in 2019 which according to their website
had One Singular aim to increase cryptocurrency
adoption so that begs the question what is the
relationship between moonpay and the supposed
celebrities and influences there helping Buy nfts
advice three times aboard a full moon
they want you to not disclose that they had
purchased isn't it a little shady that you
have the CEO of moonpay a guy called Ivan
Soto Wright who is an active participant in
the nft market who is clearly well connected
to the celebrities using his company service
who has access to Insider information
and likely knows when celebrities May
purchase an nft before they do it and surprise
surprise people started finding out that right
on numerous occasions has purchased nft projects
right before celebrities end up purchasing them
prominent crypto skeptic and author David
Gerrard had this post on his blog it was
titled cryptographers try to scam artists
again he wrote the nft grift works like
this one tell artists there's a gusher of
free money nfts are the future if you want
buy into crypto to get the gusher of free
money three they become crypto Advocates
and make excuses for proof of work and so on 4. a
few artists really are making life-changing money
from this five you probably won't be one of them
it's sold to you as this amazing thing where art
is digitally verified on the blockchain and that
pitch makes you think that on the blockchain when
you purchase an nft there's literally an entry
that shows your wallet and the actual image of
the nft you purchased right there you want to know
what is actually the case with most nfts there is
no picture attached to the transaction instead
it's usually a https or ipfs link containing
the stored nft image so what you're purchasing
with most nfts is just an entry in a database
that contains a link to the image that anyone
else can also access a little misleading to
call that ownership but I guess at the end of
the day that doesn't matter when just like icos
nfts were just another speculative give Financial
investment to throw your money into and to do that
you had to buy into cryptocurrencies
more money funneled into the machine
in my experience of looking into crypto
communities and its culture and various projects
there is this game that is being played some are
blatant about it and others less so but the game
is this everyone is playing a role in promoting
their project calling it revolutionary saying
that this isn't like the others but ultimately
everyone knows that at some point they're going
to sell and perhaps it is because of the Grateful
nature of the crypto ecosystem where everyone
is incentivized to keep putting money into the
system and to keep pushing it while simultaneously
dismissing criticism on the surface everything is
supposed to be positive and optimistic you have
catchphrases and actions that are commonly used in
cryptocurrency communities Hudl shortfall hold on
for dear life which refers to holding on to your
crypto assets no matter what hodling is seen as a
good thing today we're going to be talking about
the art of the whole wagami short for we're all
going to make it which is used as both a greeting
and an easy catchphrase to keep morale High we're
all gonna make it and I say this with passion and
confidence if you leave the market if you give up
you will lose that is the ultimate failure we're
still early is a sentiment often echoed in crypto
communities an encouraging message for those
who are both new and old in the space letting
them know that they haven't missed out on the
opportunity and further riches are on the horizon
don't abandon hope is it too late to get into
crypto no never it's never too late it's actually
too early it's extremely early still those who
hold on to their crypto assets even when there
is really good reason to sell are called Diamond
hands Diamond hands is actually a requirement
keep Diamond handing okay a positive tree that is
encouraged whereas those who do sell are labeled
paper hands a negative trait which is actively
discouraged the worst part about paper-handed
Investors is that it influences other people to
grow paper on their hands most crypto communities
are encouraged to say good morning and goodnight
to each other every day shortened to just a GM and
GN kind of like a regular check-in and check out
with members now negativity is usually handled in
the same way since one group's negativity can
actually devalue a project and affect everyone
else's ability to make money if there's some bad
news about a particular cryptocurrency project or
cryptocurrencies in general it can be dismissed as
thud abbreviation for fear uncertainty and doubt
we have someone that again is trying to spread
fun I just couldn't sit idly by him like find my
investment and fought the leader of my investment
or those who criticize are told you simply don't
understand without any further elaboration or
they're told to have fun staying poor which is
a not so subtle nod to people's true intentions
within the space or criticism is actually spun
into a good thing for the project these are all
very convenient actions to encourage when keeping
someone engaged and hopeful in a crypto project
is financially beneficial to everyone else [Music]
I'm actually struck by how much the general
public really hates it when someone gets into
nfts and they just have an absolute adverse
reaction I see this across Industries the nft
Mania did something I think it it grew so big and
so in your face from influencers and celebrities
that it started making people mad I love being
part of this community and being a voice and
sharing my platform and just getting the word
out there what community what what are you guys
talking about you don't [__] care about this
I hate that they try to put on that they care
about this Ford ape yacht club nfts which I think
are ugly dumb cringe thank you guys for allowing
me to stream about nft cartoons I hate this stuff
it's getting worse so check this out I got a board
Bunny and not only is a board bunny but it looks
like me look at that nothing makes people hate
you faster than nft Shilling if you're young and
naive just like my brother and want to get into
nfts you should check out boarding new board
bunny nft project has now been classified as
a scam welcome David doberger to the long list of
influencers promoting scams further claiming the
team has disappeared with six million dollars
it's great to be a part of this project I love
the designs inspired by Pokemon it's a Pokemon
knockoff it's just like stealing money from
people who are fans of Pokemon y'all better not
miss this they promised Pokemon Partnerships uh
all a lie and it ended up raking in 6.3 million
dollars for the last six months I've been working
on my own nft project so the project is called
cryptozoom I believe it's going to change the
game crypto Zoo Logan Paul's newest project are
basically a bunch of stock photos from Adobe that
have been poorly photoshopped unfungible tokens
yes I do know what they are but I don't [Music]
really nobody seems to like nfts we didn't find
anybody who actually had anything positive to say
about them whenever a big celebrity or influencer
would post something related to nfts on their
social media you'd see a whole slew of people
responding with oh no not you too and this wasn't
just limited to individuals either companies
began getting a lot of flack for even talking
about or dabbling into nfts in 2021 people found
out what cryptocurrency actually was and they
hated it is all get rich quick schemes promoted
using technology as the cover all of it that's
what crypto is and nft is the largest species I
think in June there were 1500 computer scientists
and technologists who wrote to Congress calling
for more responsible regulation of crypto assets
they said that catastrophes and externalities
related to blockchain Technologies and crypto
asset Investments are the inevitable outcomes
of a technology that is not built for purpose
and will remain forever unsuitable as a foundation
for large-scale economic activity and so you start
to wonder like okay like what's gonna happen
and I know that it really shouldn't surprise me
but a whole new packaging had been in the
works and a brand new word was taking the stage
our mission at moonpay on board the world to
web 3. I have to admit it's a pretty convincing
narrative the first iteration of the internet web
1.0 was essentially the first version of the web
mostly consisting of web pages and information
there wasn't much you could actually interact
with then came along Web 2.0 which brought
access to many new features it focused on
user generated content social media and more
forms of participation this version of the
internet became dominated by large corporations
Web 2.0 is our current modern day version of the
internet but now web 3.0 is coming it kind of
just referred to a bunch of different things
but the idea was that a new version of the
internet is here where your online activity
was going to be making use of blockchains and
tokens to some degree or another so in theory
the now centralized version of the internet owned
by big Tech would become owned Now by its users
in its initial bubble nfts were seen as just
digital art right which is quite limiting at
the end of the day nfts are just data on a public
database that can act as a receipt of ownership
over whatever that data contained you know whether
it was a coin or it was a web link to a digital
piece of art the idea was that if nfts could
prove ownership over something then you could
put anything on the blockchain real estate titles
medical records University degrees legal records
in the case of web 3 you'd have social media sites
and video games all incorporating blockchain and
nfts into their business model it didn't really
matter what it was or how it would work exactly
it just became this game of insert anything
here but on the blockchain and just like that
you've made it revolutionary you've just recreated
the entire mortgage infrastructure that already
existed it on the blockchain but that exactly the
blockchain in real estate is going to be pretty
mainstream five to ten years from now let's see
solar grids electric grids self-driving car grids
that will essentially be machine run and trolled
and administered by blockchain best use case for
blockchain is Healthcare what can and can't be
turned into an nft ultimately what we're talking
about is the tokenization of everything never
mind if blockchains or tokenization actually fix
the issues that it was claiming to solve in these
industries it was literally the definition of a
solution in search of a problem and then I'm lost
as to like why the on the blockchain part matters
besides basically what everyone means is they mean
oh I want a public record of the transaction okay
I mean people suggested that you could replace
legal contracts with small contracts which are
programs that are built on the blockchain and
that's usually accompanied with the phrase coder's
law this is a smart contract and this is a legal
contract these two things aren't the same right
you can't have law be enacted by computer code
because law inherently requires third parties
to assess evidence intentions and a bunch of
other variables that you just can't Outsource
that to computer code especially when that code
is on the blockchain and it cannot be altered
Nicholas Weaver a researcher and lecturer at UC
Berkeley's department for computer science has
this interview with current affairs and he brought
up what he called Weaver's iron law of blockchain
when somebody says you can solve x with blockchain
they don't understand X and you can just ignore
them so you start to wonder right who is behind
all of this money that's coming and pouring into
the crypto and web 3 space where is it coming from
and why either I'm not seeing the Revolutionary
potential that all of this has or this genuinely
is a massive Mania and bubble that is being fueled
by greed and delusion the so-called next version
of the internet that's attracting big money from
Adventure Capital Venture firm um called
Andreessen Horowitz have you guys heard of
it I kept seeing this venture capital name pop up
we've been in the space for a long time kind of a
big deal running the crypto fund with more than 7
billion in capital to deploy Andries and Horowitz
otherwise known as a16z they're one of the largest
Venture Capital firms they have a crypto fund
with around 7.6 billion to be invested in crypto
and web 3 startups and have been investing in
crypto companies dating back to 2013. if you
wanted to meet the smart money behind all of
this then these guys were the best place to
start they say that crypto is far more than
just a financial Innovation it's social cultural
technological in the month of October of 2021 a16z
led a funding of 150 million dollars towards the
company that was behind axi Infinity a16z General
partner Ariana Simpson claimed that this was an
example of where web3 is going to revolutionize
the internet in her own words literally axi
embodies a new generation of games what this means
for the future of games and really the web as we
know it is as big as your imagination will allow
where do I begin actually Infinity was what
you would call a play to earn game it was this
new genre of games appearing in the web 3 space
which as the name suggests allows players to make
money when they play the game in the case of axi
infinity what you had was this game where people
would breed collect and fight with these creatures
called axes when battling inside the game it was
possible to earn this token called SLP which could
actually be traded for real money so what started
happening well people started playing the game
but instead of focusing on the fun of the game
the focus became on how to earn more SLP how do we
profit from XC Infinity the most expensive accent
I've ever sold was worth about eight hundred
thousand dollars I've invested 13 232 dollars
is even play axi Infinity you had to purchase
three axi nfts right and as the value of axi
nfts start to rise certain players wouldn't be
able to afford the buy-in price so guess what
started happening those who had the money to
buy three axes began to lend their creatures
out to players who couldn't afford it and they
were called Scholars how to set up your own
scholarship program as a manager in axi Infinity
I'll be giving out a scholarship every two weeks
so that's another six scholarships is my goal
Scholars would then play the game using their
rented axes earn SLP and then give a cut of their
earnings to their managers my team of 12 Scholars
was roughly earning me 1 700 a month 600 from
my Scholars with all my current scholarships
working I'm earning about six thousand dollars a
month axi Infinity a play to earn crypto gaming
Juggernaut that has led people in countries like
Philippines and Venezuela to make a living these
are players from the Philippines who are making
a living playing accents most of the scholars who
couldn't afford the buy-in price they were
from developing countries right people who
likely saw actually Infinity not as a game of
leisure but as a means of producing income I am
here to apply scholarships Infinity I want this
scholarship because I want to earn more I can
play 6 to 12 hours a day just for playing after
infinity I will treat this as a job not just only
a game I want to help my family under expenses
and save up money for my tuition on college so
I want to be a scholar so that I can meet the
needs of my family what you ended up with was a
game where players are playing in order to make
money people are basically feeding their entire
villagers playing our games but the only reason
that they're making money is because others are
buying into also make money in the case of things
like actually Infinity there actually are a bunch
of innocent victims right I mean when you run a
pyramid scheme unfortunately you get a bunch of
poor people in the Philippines who are poor
when they start and they're just hoping to
make some money but then what happens is they
actually lose money the value of SLP which is
the token that people use to actually make
money in the game has fallen 99 since its
peak and its user base has been in Decline since
Times magazine came out with this article and it
was interviewing this guy called samerson orias
a line cook from the Philippines who was facing
Financial stress after his mother had a stroke
and electricity and grocery bills were stacking
up Arias jumped into the axi Infinity game
and then exited 14 months later he described
it as boring and stressful Arias along with other
players of the game told Times magazine that acts
see Infinity reinforce predatory systems and gave
them false hope it's already dystopian as hell but
people in the developing world
that's not just dark that [__]
again I find myself coming back to the
same question what is it that VC firms
are seeing the potential in in this crypto
space why do they keep pouring money into it
the overwhelming majority of tokens are our
Securities yeah but they're being dumped onto
retail investors this is being done explicitly
by Venture firms I won't mention any names who
are buying into companies early getting into
tokens and then those tokens are being listed on
exchanges the public is buying into them in order
to get a financial gain they have no interest in
using those tokens for any utility VC firms have
a commonly used strategy they invest in a bunch
of startups most of those startups will fail a few
will succeed and with the ones that succeed a VC
needs to decide on an exit strategy an event
that allows them to liquidate their position
in a company and essentially make money this is a
process that can take years so there's a another
idea that is proposed by Skeptics that the world
of crypto offers an incentive for VC firms to
invest in a crypto company receive a percentage
of their tokens and then sell those tokens to
retail Traders when it becomes publicly available
all achievable within months highly profitable
and fairly unregulated with crypto tokens they
can cash out in a few months and the way that this
actually works is they encourage their fundees to
basically issue unregistered Securities Anderson
Horowitz invested in a bunch of startups that
all issued tokens that all got dumped on retail
including Anderson Horowitz dumping a lot of
them on retail this is blatant Securities fraud
but they didn't commit the Securities fraud it
was just the companies they invested in on the
surface web3 has this narrative which is all about
taking money out of the hands of the rich and the
big Tech and giving it back to the users but a16z
is the exact same company that has funded some of
the biggest web 2 companies like Facebook and
Twitter I'm sure that there are many inside of
these firms that you know really believe in the
potential of web 3 or crypto or blockchains or
whatever buzzword you want to use but it becomes
increasingly harder to see that as anything
thing other than hyper optimism or another
word for it delusion there's this interview
with Mark Andreessen right who's the co-founder
of Andreessen Horowitz and he's on this podcast
episode with an economist and blogger called
Tyler Cohen and he proposes the idea for podcasts
to make use of web3 a well-known podcast host how
does that person get paid in a better way through
web 3.0 make that more concrete for us now Mark
Andreessen is someone that by all accounts should
have a good answer to this question but instead
yeah I mean I mean they can pick their business
model I mean they can pick their business model
they can decide you as a super based business
model you know micro transactions they can pick
you know they can pick whatever model they want
um you know they can also have indirect you
know there's this old this whole new rise of
this kind of the the non-fungible token you know
when pressed to give an actual use case what you
get is an answer with all the right buzzwords and
phrases but little actual substance I compare it
to the internet like in all seriousness I compare
it to the internet which is the internet basically
93 or so yeah it's like 93 94. this is the
only the only time I've ever said this is
like the internet is is this a16z uses the same
narrative that a lot of crypto enthusiasts will
also use you may hate it you may think it's a fad
but crypto and web 3.0 are just like the internet
even I made this comparison when I looked at the
entire space in a more favorable light now though
I just think it's another form of smoke and
mirrors it is the biggest technology shift
since the internet the blockchain the consumer
blockchain's the biggest new thing since the
internet itself Bitcoin began in 2009 arguably
blockchain technology and the foundations for it
began even earlier than that it's been 13 years
since this story began with Bitcoin 13 years
to find a solid use case or at least one that
justifies the hype and is already better than an
existing system crypto and web 3 is really great
at one bang which is trading and speculation and
there is absolutely no democratization of anything
the centralization of exchanges centralization
of miners centralization of crypto wild is the
most concentrated amount of centralized wealth
in the history of humanity worse than disease
it's all [__] 13 years after 1983 which is
considered to be the birth of the internet we
were already seeing very clear-cut use cases
even in those early days people could weather
reports they could check the news they could
send emails and many other uses that we still use
to this day I sent a message to my doctor asking
for a repeat prescription and he said he's left
the prescription for me in the chemist by even
making the comparison to one of the biggest
Revolutions in information and communication
is already assuming that cryptocurrencies are
revolutionary and they're bound to find mass
adoption at some point when that is the very
future we're putting into question [Music]
one recent post that I remember on the Bitcoin
subreddit was titled does anyone else feel like
Bitcoin is their literal last ditch effort to
become wealthy in their lifetime I don't imagine
that this is the only person in the crypto space
that is thinking that way the crypto machine has
continued running new packaging of ideas more
money funneled into the system and a constant
search to find a use case that justifies the hype
and the claims of revolutionary technology if the
critics are right then what we're looking at is
a ticking Time Bomb if the critics are right then
this is a scheme that will leave tons of regular
individuals left holding their bags wondering how
this managed to happen it already has a scheme
that managed to infiltrate the realm of media and
entertainment that managed to make use of social
media's ability to spread this fear of missing
out they capitalized on Greed and a get rich quick
mentality if the critics are right then I suppose
there's only one question that remains at what
point does the ticking Time Bomb go off [Music]